[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum Presseclub
an diesem Sonntag an dem tag 1 nach dem
sehr erstaunlichen Tag gestern am frühen
Morgen gestern haben wir erfahren dass
der Chef der wagnertruppen prigosch in
den offenen Machtkampf mit Wladimir
Putin sucht und mit seinen Truppen in
Richtung Moskau unterwegs ist der Konvoi
kommt erstaunlich schnell voran und
angeblich erst 200 km vor Moskau dann
die überraschende Kehrtwende ruft seine
Truppen Truppen zurück um Zitat ein
russisches Blutvergießen zu vermeiden
Putin der noch am Morgen von Fahrrad
gesprochen hatte garantiert im Gegenzug
Straffreiheit all dieses Hin und Her
wollen wir heute im Presseclub
beleuchten unser Thema Aufstand in
Russland erodiert Putins macht und das
sind meine Gäste auf die ich mich sehr
freue Katrin Eugendorf sie ist
internationale Reporterin für das ZDF
Christoph Schilz er ist Korrespondent in
Brüssel für die Welt Welt am Sonntag
zuständig für und EU-Berichterstattung
Anastasia tiramirova sie ist freie
Journalistin mit dem Schwerpunkt
Osteuropa und Thomas avenarius er ist
auslands- und krisenreporter der
Süddeutschen Zeitung in allen herzlich
willkommen
vorab möchte ich aber gerne noch mal
einen aktuellen Blick auf die Situation
werfen und zwar mit meiner korresponden
meiner Kollegin Ina Ruck im Studio
Moskau sie ist uns live zugeschaltet von
vor Ort Ina du hast im Moment sehr viel
zu tun danke für deine Zeit vielleicht
kannst du uns kurz schildern wie die
aktuelle Situation sich in Moskau heute
morgen darstellt
also hier in Moskau als wäre nichts
gewesen der Verkehr läuft ganz normal
die Leute gehen spazieren ich bin gerade
in der Stadt unterwegs gewesen man merkt
nichts man hat auch gestern wenig
gemerkt ehrlich gesagt es war ein
bisschen mehr Polizei da als sonst aber
vom an die Terror-Regime war so richtig
deutlich außer an den Ausfahrten aus der
Stadt nicht viel zu spüren dieses Anti
terror-regim hat der präsidentensprecher
gerade in der Minute gesagt werde jetzt
demnächst auch aufgehoben also es wirkt
als sei da so ein Spuk gewesen der ist
jetzt aber wieder vorbei und man tut so
als sei alles ganz normal aber normal
ist natürlich gar nichts hier im Moment
wie schätzt du denn diesen 24 Stunden
Aufstand ein der jetzt abgeblasen wurde
was für Spekulation was für
Möglichkeiten gibt es wie es jetzt
weitergehen könnte
ganz schwer zu sagen was das eigentlich
war ich glaube man kann relativ sicher
sagen ohne viel zu spekulieren dass das
für Putin einen katastrophaler Tag war
dass diese Macke wird bleiben
möglicherweise ist er jetzt angezählt
das ist noch ein bisschen früh
vielleicht zu sagen aber für ihn ist das
ein ganz ganz schwerer Tag gewesen er
hat sich da vorführen lassen müssen mehr
oder weniger er hat eben übrigens das
hat der Pressesprecher auch noch mal
gesagt noch mal sich bedankt bei
Lukaschenko für die Vermittlung also
bist schon unglaublich alles ich denke
aber und das ist eine andere Spekulation
die sich hier verfestigt es ist kaum
vorstellbar dass pregorian diese ganze
Nummer alleine gemacht hat also dass er
nicht vorher sich irgendwo eine
Absicherung geholt hat dass er
möglicherweise sogar in den
Sicherheitskreisen hier in den Eliten
irgendwo Verbündete setzen hat die noch
nicht aus der Deckung kommen mir sieht
das alles aus nach einem Gerangel
im inneren Zirkel nach einem Art
infighting und wir müssen so hart das
klingt gucken wer am Ende überlebt also
wer politisch überlebt dann wissen wir
was das Ganze da war ja vielen Dank Ina
live für diese Einschätzungen heute
direkt aus Moskau wir werden das Thema
jetzt hier natürlich weiter diskutieren
und du wirst weiter darüber berichten
wenn sie sich übrigens beteiligen wollen
können Sie das in den sozialen Medien
gerne tun wir streamen den Presseclub in
den üblichen auf den üblichen Plattform
melden Sie sich gerne mit Fragen und
Einlassungen zum Thema jetzt aber
endlich diese Runde ist eröffnet wir
haben es ja gerade gesehen angeblich 200
km vor Moskau wurden diese Soldaten
gestoppt sogar der tschetschenenführer
kadiro hatte sich schon auf den Weg
gemacht um Putin zu unterstützen Frau
Eugendorf wie knapp ist Russland gestern
möglicherweise ein Putsch entkommen oder
sogar ein Bürgerkrieg was würden Sie
jetzt im Rückblick sagen obwohl es ja
erstmal jetzt abgebrochen wurde ja ich
glaube das ist erst der Anfang einer
Entwicklung also sicherlich ist Russland
knapp auf einer blutigen
Auseinandersetzung aus dem Weg gegangen
aber was wir natürlich erleben ist eine
Erosion der politischen Macht eines
Führers dessen im Prinzip Hauptsäule der
macht ja der starke Führer war das hat
Putin an die Macht gebracht
unerbitterliche Härte den Russen zu
versichern Russland ist wieder groß ein
starkes Land und ihr habt einen Führer
der hier mit harter Hand durchregiert
das funktioniert nicht mehr dieses diese
Säule der Macht ist nun in ihrem
Fundament schwer erschüttert worden und
ich sehe Putin in der größten Krise seit
seiner Amtszeit wenn ich mir die Lage
heute angucke und was ja auch
interessant ist
Russland das ein Meister der Propaganda
ist ist auf einmal ohne narrativ wir
sehen einen Putin der gestern noch ähm
pregorien als Hochverräter bezeichnet
hat und ihn praktisch zum Abschluss
freigegeben hat um das mal so salopp zu
sagen und was ist der heute ist es redet
keiner mehr von Hochverrat und das ist
natürlich interessant wie will man das
den Menschen in Russland erklären ich
sehe hier keine narrativ und das ist ein
großes Problem
begreifen wir natürlich gleich noch auf
Frau tiramiro war wir haben es ja gerade
bei Ina Ruck gehört also wahrscheinlich
ist es so dass brigorien Unterstützung
auch hatte ein größeres Netzwerk dass er
jetzt nicht ein alleiniger Kämpfer an
der Stelle war mit seinen Truppen wie
groß glauben sie ist da möglicherweise
noch die Unterstützung also was könnte
auch wieder aufflammen nach der jetzt
erstmal Beruhigung die Stadt gefunden
hat das erste Mal wenn wir in die
russische Bevölkerung schauen wir haben
gesehen wie Wagner empfangen wurde mit
mit selfies mit Umarmungen die Leute
haben gejubelt als in die Stadt kamen es
sind jetzt die Bilder
auch in der Tagesschau genau ich hatte
gestern abend die Möglichkeit mit einem
Journalisten außer das Dorf zu sprechen
und er berichtete mir von sehen dass
junge Leute arme Menschen auf die
Straßen gingen und eben mit diesen halt
dann abgehangen haben und er hat dort
Gespräche gehört wie naja diese Schurken
in im Kreml die bereichern sich an
unserem Geld und schicken dann unsere
Jungs in den Tod also man muss schon
verstehen dass brigagen als erster so
publik ausgesprochen hat was eigentlich
passiert also seine Kritik an Scheu Go
ist ja durchaus legitim er hat
kritisiert das shagout diese russischen
jungen Männer unvorbereitet in den
sicheren Tod sendet und das wird nicht
spurlos an der russischen Bevölkerung
Vorbeigehen sie haben jetzt die Szenen
auf aus Rostock am donnern beschrieben
das ist ja sehr nah an der Grenze zur
Ukraine her avenarius glauben Sie dass
das was die Kollegin gerade beschrieben
hat insgesamt auch für Russland gelten
kann wie viel Rückhalt hat
möglicherweise gregorien dort in der
Bevölkerung und wie gefährlich könnte
das noch werden für Putin ist natürlich
sehr schwer zu messen aber eine
Erfahrung der russischen Geschichte ist
das auch früher und Rebellen sehr
geschätzt werden also das ist der Rebell
ist eine Figur in der russischen
Geschichte der immer Zulauf findet und
Gregor durch seine Sprache durch sein
Auftreten durch dieses kumpelhaft Knast
geprägter Auftreten der spricht die
Leute an da muss man sich nichts
vormachen und insofern glaube ich dass
er sehr sehr gefährlich ist und das
zweite ist er kriegt natürlich auch
Zuspruch weil er die Wahrheit sagt also
alles was er über den Krieg in der
Ukraine gesagt hat stimmt daran ist
nichts falsch daran ist nichts
übertrieben da sind Dilettanten in
Generalstab am Berg da ist ein
Verteidigungsminister der sein Geschäft
offenbar nicht wirklich beherrscht die
Schlachten die die Russen verlieren sind
lehrbuchmäßig verloren also vieles was
was dieser Mann sagt ist richtig und das
wird schon schwierig für Putin und das
wird ihm gewissen support in der
Bevölkerung schon verschaffen nun ist es
ja so also US-Geheimdienst Quellen sagen
ja tatsächlich das der besten schon
vorher informiert war das ist da
aufstand und Unruhe geben könnte
möglicherweise sogar Putin selbst war
vorher informiert über diesen Aufstand
ähm herrschings wie schätzen Sie das
denn ein also wenn man es vorher wusste
gibt es eine Erklärung dafür warum Putin
es trotzdem so lange hat laufen lassen
also warum ist es überhaupt so weit in
dieser Eskalation gekommen wir wissen es
nicht aber ich bitte zu bedenken und da
möchte ich Kathrin Eigendorf auch
widersprechen das ist auch ganz anders
sein könnte und dafür spricht eben diese
Geheimnis Erkenntnisse wir erinnern uns
an den Aufstand in der Türkei 2016 das
war so eine Art kontrollierter
Putschversuch und wir sollten darüber
nachdenken ob dies nicht auch ein
inszenierter oder
kontrollierter Putschversuch war macht
ihr Rover sagen die Russen dazu das ist
ein bewusstes Täuschungsmanöver und ich
möchte behaupten Putin hat
möglicherweise ich weiß es nicht aber
Tuttlingen hat möglicherweise von diesem
Putschversuch sogar profitiert weil er
hat und er hat sich stabilisiert es ist
das Gegenteil dessen was Sie gesagt
haben aber mich wundert schon dass ein
oder andere und ich möchte es
formulieren warum ist beispielsweise
warum sind die Soldaten ungehindert so
lange durchmarschiert warum wird
pregosin in einem Land und seine Truppe
werden freigesprochen werden dort wird
eine Fahne hochgehalten ein Plakat und
schon wird man inhaftiert Putin hat
alles erreicht was er in seiner
dramatischen Rede gestern Morgen
gefordert hat Einheit und die Schwächung
des Landes alles ist auf einmal hat sich
erledigt warum sollte pregosch in einer
extrem wichtigen Phase dieses Krieges wo
die Ukraine kurz vor ihrer angekündigten
Großoffensive stehen
derartige Unordnung und Chaos schaffen
dass die dass die russischen
Streitkräfte vor Ort so geschwächt
werden also mir geht das auch alles zu
schnell für mich war es ein Rebellion
München und ein wahrscheinlich in
szeniertes Rebellion München und welchen
Effekt wenn ich das noch sagen darf
welchen Effekt soll dieses inszenierte
haben
ein mobilisierungseffekt natürlich die
Kriegsanstrengungen Putins könnten
möglicherweise verstärkt werden die
Mobilisierung der eigenen Bevölkerung da
die ja ganz wichtig ist für Putin aber
auch die Mobilisierung der Soldaten wir
werden möglicherweise jetzt große
Veränderungen im
Verteidigungsministerium sehen und für
die Ukraine wird das alles noch viel
schlimmer werden es hat also kein
entlastenden Effekt sondern ein
Resüme ist gerade mal weil hier sich
schon Widerstand regte also sie sagen
wenn man es so betrachtet dass man sagt
das ist tatsächlich seitens putinen
inszeniert worden in Absprache mit wem
auch immer dass die rein sich hinter ihm
schließen können weil es gibt die
Bedrohungen gegenüber seiner Führung da
haben sie sich ja jetzt ganz klar gegen
Frau Eigendorf positioniert ich sage die
Fakten sprechen dagegen weil wir sehen
ja keinen gestärkten Putin sondern ein
deutlich geschwächten Putin gucken wir
doch mal zurück auf die russische
Geschichte was hat den Putin an die
Macht gebracht
die harte Haltung gegen den Terror aus
Tschetschenien hat Putin zur
Präsidentschaft verholfen seine immer
wieder wiederholte Haltung wir
verhandeln nicht mit Terroristen die
stellen wir an die Wand ja das ist das
was Putin bei der russischen Bevölkerung
beliebt gemacht hat und dass er viele
Lügen narrative verbreitet das ist
Korruption gibt das hat man alles
hingenommen hat die russische
Bevölkerung immer hingenommen weil eben
das für die glaube ich Mehrheit der
Russen das Wichtige ist sie haben einen
starken Führer so und diesen starken
Führer sehe ich nicht mehr wir haben
hier einen Präsidenten der ein
totalitäres Regime errichtet hat der im
Prinzip Terroristen freies Geleit
gegeben hat die wagnertruppe ist eine
irreguläre seltene Truppe die einen
putschbesuch gegen den russischen Staat
unternommen hat interessant ist die
Frage wie konnten sie ist tatsächlich
schon so weit durch zu marschieren da
muss man sich einfach auch mal angucken
und da bin ich ganz bei Ihnen auch wie
weit geht eigentlich der zurückhalt für
pregorian und die Tatsache dass Putin
sich das so lange angeschaut hat da sehe
ich ein ganz anderen Grund er war auf
Wagner Truppen angewiesen Putins macht
fußte auf dem Erfolg dieser seltener
Truppe weil das Militär sicher in so
vielen Krisen als unfähig erwiesen hat
also eher etwas was Putin jetzt
geschadet hat was dagegen sprechen würde
dass es ein inszeniertes
bleibt aber bei seinem Blick auf die
Dinge auch die die ganze Nummer wenn ich
das so sagen darf mit Lukas schenko ein
ein Putin sie denn als Handlanger an das
Verhältnis zulokal schenko ist sehr
schlecht und den ausgerechnet setzte als
Mediator ein und dem gelingt es danach
wenigen Stunden
und auch noch dazu zu bringen nach
Belarus zu gehen was wird er denn da
machen im Schaukelstuhl sitzen bestimmt
nicht das wissen wir alle noch nicht
machen aber wir wissen auch noch nicht
ich möchte das noch mal sagen wir wissen
noch nicht ob Putin aus diesem Aufstand
hervorgeht ich sehe das noch nicht ja
ich würde sagen dass ich diese
Schwächung von Putin auf jeden Fall sehe
also ich glaube dass dieser Aufstand
brigorsions zwar nicht plötzlich kam
sondern länger geplant gewesen ist
weil er seine Entmachtung
entgegengesehen hat also Putin hat ja
tatsächlich eine Armee oder die
russischen Streitkräfte bestehen aus
mehreren Parteien um eben eine
Entmachtung Putins zu verhindern also
Putin hat eine so große Paranoia dass er
unglaublich viele Parteien in seiner
Armee hat also wir haben da natürlich
die Wagner PMC wir haben die regulären
russischen Streitkräfte wir haben die
Armeen der
netzrepubliken und so weiter und so fort
und damit wollte Putin verhindern also
durch diese Interessensgruppen pflegte
die von Pudding geschürt wurden wollte
er verhindern dass jemand stärker wird
als er aber schon ist immer stärker
geworden und hat als eben gesagt wurde
okay ähm
wagnertruppe soll sich jetzt mal in die
russische Armee integrieren
da ist schon aufgemuckt und er hat
eigentlich damit was er sich gestern
geleistet hat erreicht dass er das nicht
mehr tun muss also Wagner kann autonom
bleiben es wurde Wagner angeboten sich
freiwillig in die russische Armee zu
integrieren sie müssen aber nicht die
kann an der Spitze bleiben und er hat es
geschafft dass er nicht macht wird die
Frage natürlich die sich jetzt ergibt
wer bleibt der mächtig im Land in einer
Diktatur wie Russland ist heute eine ist
können nicht zwei mächtige Männer an der
Spitze sein und deswegen ist es nur eine
Frage der Zeit bis entweder Putin oder
privat gehen oder vielleicht noch ein
dritter ankommt ich möchte aber gerne
die Theorie des inszenierten Rebellion
Münchens auch noch an Herrn avenarius
weitergeben
ich würde da auch von Herzen
widersprechen also lassen wir den Film
doch noch mal Ablaufen der Leib Koch und
Vorkoster das Kreml Chefs kriegt Panzer
nach Moskau
die Russen die moskau ist offenbar nicht
in der Lage sich zu verteidigen und
fängt an Schützengräben vor den Städten
auszuheben da kann Putin ja nicht mehr
stark wirken dann kommt es zu einem
sogenannten gentlemanagement von zwei
Leuten die keine Gentleman sind aber
löst sich alles ein bisschen Sekunde
bitte löst sich das alles in
Wohlgefallen auf Nein putin ist massiv
gebe ich Ihnen Recht und gebe ich
Kathrin und und der Kollegin rechts und
die entscheidende Frage ist das was Ina
angedeutet hat Kriegerin ist nicht
alleine marschiert der hat einen
Rückhalt gehabt in den Diensten im
Militär und diese Leute haben offenbar
entweder das kalte Füße bekommen oder
sie haben sich zurückgezogen weil sie
ihr Ziel erreicht hatten putin ist der
samuiiert und wer will denn mit
gregorien umgehen das ist ja eine
Hitzkopf ein jetzt mal überspitz gesagt
wahnsinniger mit dem kommt man ja nicht
zurecht jetzt hat man zwei Fliegen mit
einer Klappe geschlagen putin ist massiv
geschwächt und für Deutschland ist
erstmal über die Grenze kann man später
sehen wie das dann weitergeht also
geschwächt ist Putin auf jeden Fall und
massiv und vielleicht damit auch in
Europa wieder völlig Recht ist der
Anfang des Endes von Putin vielleicht
kann das aber auch stabilisieren und
wurscht so weiter wie ihr seit langer
Zeit weiter wurscht nur einen Satz noch
seit Kriegsbeginn am 24 Februar hat
Putin eine Niederlage an die andere
Gehalt er hat keinen einzigen Erfolg
gehabt als folgt eine Niederlage der
anderen und jetzt das und passt dann mit
diesem Söldnerführer also
das war gestern interessant viele waren
ja schon in der Stimmung im Laufe des
Samstags das wird ein Bürgerkrieg geben
und das hat Russland noch nie erlebt um
8 Uhr gestern Morgen hat eine russische
Journalist äh Analytikerin Berliner
chakarova die lange Zeit die Leiterin
war des österreichischen Instituts für
Sicherheitspolitik geschrieben dies ist
ein Machtkampf zwischen den ST
Petersburger Putin geträumt und in
Moskauer Putin geträumt und der
Schoßhund für ihn tut was putin will
und sie hat damals schon gesagt gestern
schon gesagt
wird nicht verhaftet werden genauso ist
es gekommen und was sie auch geschrieben
hat ist dies ist der Auftakt zum
Wahlkampf Putins im nächsten Jahr sind
ja Präsidentschaftswahlen in Russland
und ich bitte das einfach nur zu
bedenken und das ist auch ganz anders
sein gewesen sein könnte ich bin auch
nicht sicher und die Leute die ich
gestern bei der NATO gesprochen habe
sind auch nicht sicher ja und offenbar
sind auch die
Geheimdienstberichte nicht nicht
eindeutig ich bitte das nur nur zu
bedenken dass es so sein könnte
vielleicht wir spekulieren ja jetzt auch
aber es ist ja interessant das Ganze aus
verschiedenen äh Sichtweisen zu
betrachten gleich ich wollte an der
Stelle einen Aspekt reinbringen sie
haben gerade gesagt ist natürlich da so
eine Art Schoßhund von Putin und muss
tun was der will gleichzeitig hat auch
ein User hier auf Twitter gefragt was
ich auch schon als Frage vorbereitet
hatte ihn würde es interessieren wie es
zusammen passt das im monatelang er
bittert auf der russischen Seite kämpft
in Geburt ja die einzigen Geländegewinne
letztendlich organisieren konnte und
dann auf einmal die in Moskau genannten
Kriegsgründe offiziell angezweifelt hat
also ist er wirklich so dass er
Freitagabend in einem wütenden Interview
mehr oder weniger gesagt hat ja hier
wurde behauptet die Ukraine und die NATO
wollen gegen Russland marschieren das
stimmt alles nicht das ist eine
selbstinszenierungsshow von Herrn
schulgut dem Verteidigungsminister und
seinem generalstaatschef also mit diesem
Interview was er am Freitag in die Welt
gesetzt hat hat er ja quasi die
offizielle Kriegspropaganda die
militärische spezialoperation Propaganda
von 16 Monaten eingerissen
wie verstehen sie das und vor allem wie
kommt die Propaganda da jetzt wieder
raus das haben wir ja schon angerissen
das Thema wie ich eben erwähnt hatte
denke ich dass es damit zusammenhängt
dass schon so der eigenen Entmachtung
entgehen wollte also am ersten 7 hatte
man zu integrieren und ich glaube er hat
ja schon gezündelt die letzten Monate er
hat schon immer mehr kritisiert und ich
glaube er ist zu stark geworden ich
glaube er ist zu stark geworden und hat
dann seine Chance gewittert eben die
russische Kriegsführung zu kritisieren
ein Punkt worauf ich noch entgegenden
wollte putin ist auf jeden Fall nicht
stärker geworden durch diese durch
diesen Putsch versucht durch diesen
Aufstand wir haben es auch alleine
gesehen an der Reaktion der Eliten die
Propagandisten die sonst immer so laut
sind Simon Jahren haben so laut
geschwiegen sie haben so laut
geschwiegen ähm bis zum nächsten
Nachmittag Putin ähm hat eine Rede
gehalten wo er tatsächlich die
Geschehnisse mit dem Jahr 1917
verglichen hat mit der russischen
Revolution das zeigt wie viel Angst er
hatte also der König der Kaiser der
Imperator der entmachtet werden soll und
dann natürlich diese diese Sendung diese
Nachrichtensendung die wir gesehen haben
mitten in der Nacht um 82 wurde die
Nachrichtensprecherin aus dem Bett
geklingelt damit sie im ersten Kanal
Nachrichten Fernsehen sagen sollte es
ist eigentlich alles gut machen Sie sich
keine Sorgen aber das zeigt ja
eigentlich wie sehr sie alle in Panik
versetzt waren plus natürlich niemand
wusste was zu tun ist also ich denke es
gibt da unterschiedliche Ansichten aber
ob die hätte die Chance gehabt Moskau
einzunehmen weil es zu wenig Widerstand
gegeben hätte weil die Leute nicht gegen
die eigene Armee also Teil der eigenen
Armee vorgehen wollen mit denen Sie so
viele Monate gekämpft haben ja jetzt
sind wir im Bereich der Spekulation hat
ganz viel mit den Kopf geschüttelt aber
ich war ja jetzt schon beim nächsten
Kapitel bei der Propaganda wir wissen es
ja nicht ob sie bis Moskau gekommen
wären oder nicht sie haben ja vorher
gestoppt so aber das Propaganda Problem
ist narrativ haben sie gerade angedeutet
ist ja in der Welt also pregorian hat
Freitag Abend sehr klar gesagt die
militärische spezialoperation wurde für
fondu inszeniert und letztendlich war
die Ukraine mit der NATO gar nicht dabei
Russland anzugreifen was muss die
Propaganda in Russland jetzt tun wie
kann sie das Aufgreifen ich sehe da im
Moment überhaupt gar keine Chance dass
sie das aufgreifen können und das ist
ein Zeichen mehr für die Schwächung
dieses Regimes wir erleben ja hier ein
prigorian ist nicht der Schoß und Putins
darüber über diese Rolle ist der weit
hinausgewachsen es ist sicherlich einer
der schwersten Kriegsverbrecher den
dieses Land aufzuweisen hat das dürfen
wir nicht vergessen wir reden hier wenn
wir über die schlimmsten
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine und auch
in Syrien reden von der Truppe die dafür
unter anderem verantwortlich ist das ist
eine Truppe die über eine große
Machtbasis auch in der Welt verfügt ja
ich meine
Rings Truppe sichert Diktaturen in
Afrika militärisch ab der Mann ist in
der Lage
diesen Sammer durchmacht dieses Regime
deutlich kräftiger in Frage zu stellen
glaube ich als das bis jetzt klar
geworden ist und was auch interessant
ist er ist ein Meister der Kommunikation
er hat sich ja im Prinzip als der
antiputin präsentiert der Mann in
Uniform Haudegen der an der Front war er
hat ja auch Putins macht nie wirklich in
Frage gestellt
sind die Militärs grassimov und scheo
das waren die Leute die er bekämpft hat
und dieses narrativ ist ja im Lauf
Kriegsverlauf immer weiter gewachsen die
Kritik und dass er selber sagen wir
jetzt den Krieg in der Ukraine in Frage
stellt erstaunt mich gar nicht so sehr
Weilchen ist kein Ideologe der kämpft
den Kampf den er kämpfen soll das ist
ein Prinzip ein Kriegsverbrecher das ist
eine Söldnertruppe die stürzen heute in
kommunistisches Regime Morgen und
faschistisches Regime ich bin mir nicht
so sicher ob das Kriegsziel der Ukraine
für ihn in der Ukraine für ihn den
Vorrang vor dem Willen zu Entmachtung
der aus seiner Sicht unfähigen Militärs
hat ich denke das ist für ihn das
Hauptziel wir dürfen nicht unterschätzen
wie weit seine Unterstützung auch in der
Bevölkerung doch zu gehen scheint in den
elit das sehe ich auch so wie Ina Ruck
aber auch in der Bevölkerung hat er sich
ja sehr geschickt zum Sprachrohr der
unzufriedenen gemacht und es gibt in
Russland sehr sehr viele unzufriedene
Bürger und das Interessante ist das sind
nicht nur die Liberalen sondern es gibt
auch sehr sehr viele unzufriedene
extreme Nationalisten und so ein Mann
den sie gerade beschrieben haben so
stark so gut vernetzt so mächtig der
soll sich in einem drei Stunden Gespräch
von Lukaschenko ausgerechnet von
Lukaschenko dem belarussischen
Machthaber überzeugen lassen haben nach
Belarus zu gehen und dort möglicherweise
im Schaukelstuhl zu sitzen das wäre dann
richtig tun aber
wird Ihnen das nicht etwas künstlich
nicht etwas inszeniert ja ich
verschenken ausgerechnet diese Problem
bei Russland ist ähm das sind alles sehr
westliche Herangehensweisen der
Erklärung ja das ähm ich kann ihrer
Kritik da folgen und ihrer Sichtweise
sind sehr westliche Sichtweise auf die
Ereignisse in Russland
funktioniert nach eigenen Maßstäben und
ich lege jetzt einfach mal die
russischen Maßstäbe an wir wissen doch
gar nicht was frigojin ausgehandelt hat
wir wissen auch gar nicht welche Rolle
Lukaschenko gespielt hat wie gesagt das
narrativ ist noch offen
lukaschen
sein der für Putin das erledigt hat
damit er nicht sich oder seinem Mann da
in die Verhandlungen reinschicken muss
das ist doch das Entspannen wir jetzt in
der an der Entwicklung was mich auch
interessiert was was passiert denn jetzt
mit Gregorian vielleicht an dem Punkt
auch noch die Frage Herr aber wenn alles
auch wenn Sie sie nicht beantworten
werden können sie haben ja gerade gesagt
Frau Eigendorf ähm hat vor allem den
Sicherheitsapparat in Moskau kritisiert
Verteidigungsminister schon gut
generalstoffchef gerassimov und es gibt
Gerüchte die sagen das Teil des Deals
sein könnte dass die jetzt abgesetzt
werden da gibt's keine offizielle
Bestätigung zu
wissen wir alles nicht also was würde
für die eine oder andere Variante
sprechen aus ihrer Lesart der russischen
Welt die wir ja nicht nur mit unseren
westlichen Augen sehen können also meine
les hat auf die Frage nach dem Schicksal
von das Generalstabschefs und des
Verteidigungsministers ist die wenn
diese beiden Leute innerhalb des
nächsten Monats entlassen werden dann
ist Putin vollends blamiert weil dann
hört er auf das Kommando eines
söldnerführers und bildet deswegen sein
Kabinett und seine Militärführung es
kann aber beim besten Willen nicht
machen so also da muss zumindest eine
längere Frist vergehen und ihre Frage
nach dem Propaganda narrativ dass man
jetzt noch auftischen kann gebe ich
Katrin völlig recht das einzige was man
jetzt noch machen kann ist das Ganze
nach außen drehen und wie üblich den
Westen beschuldigen nur ich weiß nicht
ob das irgendjemand noch glauben wird
weil es ein bisschen auch wenn die
Amerikaner offenbar sehr früh Bescheid
wussten also ich finde all diese diese
Konstellation da gebe ich gebe ich
Katrin auch noch mal recht also Russland
folgt sehr eigenen Regeln und wenn man
dann überlegt was hat denn die letzten
Monate gemacht der hat immer gesagt ich
kriege keine Munition ich ziehe ab er
hat gedroht und geht immer Schritt vor
zwei zurück Stück einen vor drei vor
zwei zurück und vielleicht ist das was
er jetzt gemacht hat genau wieder das
vielleicht ist es wieder dieses ein
Schritt vor zwei zurück zwei voreinen
zurück ich bin nicht sicher dass der
Mann weg vom Fenster ist das glaube ich
nicht sondern der wird wieder eine Rolle
spielen und ich bleibe dabei zu
widersprechen dass es für Putin was ein
massiver Schlag ins Kontor war was da
gestern und vorgestern passiert ist dazu
übrigens möchte ich gerne noch mal zwei
User von Twitter mit reinbringen also
die auch das so sehen wie sie Putin hat
verloren kein vorwärts und schon gar
kein zurück stellt sich die Frage wie
kommt der da unbeschadet raus und ein
anderer User fragt gedemütigte
Narzissten Fliegen ihre Niederlagen zu
kompensieren was ist da zu erwarten ist
eine weitere gegebenenfalls eratische
Eskalation durch Putin jetzt
wahrscheinlicher geworden
wir wissen es alle nicht aber was wie
viel eratischer soll es noch gehen würde
ich mich fragen also ähm wo soll die
Eskalation worin soll die Eskalation
liegen also das ist sicherlich eine
interessante Frage aber ich habe da
keine Antwort wie weit
das dieses Regime ist ja in der
Eskalationsstufe schon so weit gegangen
auch gegen seine eigenen Interessen und
das hat sich ja gegen Russland gewendet
dass ich nicht sehe dass das zu Erfolg
verhelfen wird und dass das überhaupt
eine Option ist
naja aber es gibt natürlich immer noch
Eskalationsstufen weil es eine Atom
macht ist Russland hat Atomwaffen Putin
hat Atomwaffen und man muss jetzt nicht
dieses schwarze Gemälde an die Wand mal
dass er die auch einsetzen wird aber
Eskalationsstufen gibt es im Ukraine
Krieg noch einige glaube ich das Putin
da auch durchaus aus weil ich meine
überfahren kann es gibt dieses
familientattoom Kraftwerk es gibt die
Nuklearwaffen es gibt die Chemie
Waffenfabrik am Eingang zur Krim also
wir haben ja an der Sache mit dem
Fahrrad Namen gesehen das tut die nicht
zurückschaut vor solchen Waffen da
machen sich übrigens auch Menschen
Sorgen darüber wie sind die
Nuklearwaffen eigentlich gesichert wer
übernimmt die Kontrolle darüber wenn es
einen Machtvakuum und Putin herum gibt
das ist jetzt natürlich alles
zukunftspekulation aber er stellt wie
wie sehen sie mögliche weitere
Eskalation selbst haben wir schon auf
einem hohen Niveau unterwegs sind in
Russland ich glaube nicht dass Protein
taktische Atomwaffen einsetzen wird
dafür ist die Schwelle viel zu hoch da
gibt es auch glaube ich noch ein paar
sperren im System dort ich denke da
müssen wir keine Angst Vorhaben
ich glaube aber auf der Basis meiner
These des inszenierten rebellinchens
das pregoschin gestärkt heraus daraus
hervorgehen wird aus diesem Machtkampf
und auch sein Einfluss auf den Ukraine
Krieg zunehmen wird er hat ja immer
gesagt das ist alles zu weich wir sind
nicht hart genug wir müssen mehr
angreifen und ich denke dass es
Veränderungen geben wird im
Verteidigungsministerium vielleicht
nicht sofort wie sie gesagt haben aber
die wird es geben
und das die Auseinandersetzung in der
Ukraine härter werden und härter geführt
werden wird aus von den Russen und das
ist eine sehr schlechte Nachricht für
die Ukraine werden groß Offensive ja
bevorsteht und der entgegen Offensive
die seit Anfang Juni läuft nicht so gut
läuft wie wir alle gehofft hatten genau
ich hätte jetzt auch den Bogen
geschlagen zu was bedeutet das für den
Krieg das haben sie jetzt wunderbar
getan die Frage gebe ich an Frau war
weiter
ist gerade beschrieben worden es könnte
sein dass
freiere Hand bekommt nach seiner Art den
Krieg zu führen er war ja immer ein
Hardliner an der Stelle wie blicken Sie
darauf was das jetzt für Auswirkungen
haben könnte genau ich denke man darf
bei alledem bei dem revolutionären
Antlitz was gestern pregorien versucht
hat zu symbolisieren er ist nach wie vor
ein Hardliner ist ein Rechtsextremist
und er hat genug Signale Ziele in der
Ukraine er hat oft darüber gesprochen
ohne Blatt von Mund zu nehmen und
deshalb denke ich das hatte ich auch
gestern sehr klar betont dass dieser
Aufstand den Zielen der Ukraine nicht
schaden soll also das selbst wenn jetzt
mehr die Oberhand an der Front gewinnt
es weitergehen wird gestern hat bei mir
die Hoffnung bestanden dass tatsächlich
dieses Zeitfenster etwas länger gehen
wird also dieses Haus und Russland was
er wie selenski genannt hatte und das
der ukrainischen gegen Offensive die
Möglichkeit geben wird weiter
vorzurücken sie haben ein paar
Stellungen in der oberste sind
vorgerückt aber natürlich 24 Stunden
reichen bei weitem nicht aus genau und
ein Punkt der mir vielleicht noch
wichtig wäre ist weil vorhin die
Opposition in Russland erwähnt wurde
also die nationalistische Opposition die
liberale Opposition in Russland hat auf
dieses ganze Scharmützel da auch mit
großer Sorge geblickt mir wurde gesagt
dass ich gestern ein Aktivisten aus
Moskau interviewt habe das ist nicht
unser Krieg also dieser Krieg zwischen
Putin und aber egal wer jetzt kommt ob
Putin und es wird schlimmer werden weil
durch dieses Scharmützel die Paranoia
die Putin hat größer wird das heißt
Russland wird noch autoritärer werden es
wird vielleicht das Kriegsrecht
eingeführt vielleicht wird mehr
mobilisiert vielleicht wird es noch
drakonischere Strafen für Oppositionelle
geben und ich denke das ist alle mal die
Folge um sich am an den Thron zu
klammern aber auch wenn privat an die
Macht gekommen wäre das will man keinem
wünschen hat gesagt dass man diese
Oppositionellen Parasiten überhaupt
nicht aus dem Land lassen sondern sie
direkt an die Front befördern sollte
deshalb für Russland also für das
demokratische Deutschland sieht die
Zukunft düster aus für den Sieg in der
Ukraine naja auf lange Sicht wir können
wir können schauen vielleicht sind die
russischen Truppen jetzt dermaßen
demoralisiert und verwirrt dass sie
nicht mehr so geschlossen agieren können
in der Ukraine deshalb bin ich
persönlich noch hoffnungsvoll das ist
auf einen langfristigen
musikvideokraining hinausläuft jetzt
greife ich mal auf sie haben ja gerade
die Möglichkeit beschrieben dass das
Kriegsrecht in Russland verhängt werden
könnte da hat jetzt wiederum Herr Schilz
genickt weil egal ob es ein inszeniertes
München war oder ein eine wirkliche
Katastrophe für Putin er könnte am Ende
so reagieren dass er z.B über das
Kriegsrecht noch mal die Situation in
Russland verschärft vor Eigendorf was
meinen Sie wie wirkt sich das auf den
Krieg aus wissen dass das eigentliche
Chaos jetzt nur 24 Stunden gedauert hat
aber möglicherweise ja trotzdem
Auswirkungen auch in der Front
feststellen sind
ja was interessantes wir haben ja
gestern die Ukraine anders als
vielleicht von manchen erwartet nicht in
heller Freude gesehen sondern durchaus
mit großer Skepsis also
meine Kontakte in der Ukraine haben auf
die Frage was bedeutet das jetzt fast
übereinstimmt gesagt ja dort ist ein
interner Machtkampf entstanden aber Kiew
wurde trotzdem mit Raketen angegriffen
es sind trotzdem Leute gestorben also
für den Krieg in der Ukraine sehe ich
nicht dass sich der positiv im Moment
für die Ukraine auswirken kann
wir würden können damit rechnen dass
sich vielleicht die frontverläufe etwas
verschieben also was wir von Soldaten
hören ist es ja durchaus so dass sie vor
allem in der Region dann jetzt und auch
interessant im Süden Russlands teilweise
weiter marschiert sind ohne auf großen
Widerstand zu stoßen also mancher
Kommandeur und vielleicht auch einfache
Soldat wird sich vielleicht in der
Ukraine Fragen also russische Soldat
oder russische Kommandeur was eigentlich
noch das Ziel seines Einsatzes hier ist
aber ich sehe nicht dass das schon Ende
des Krieges in der Ukraine ist also dazu
ist das Land einfach zu weit gegangen
das ist eben wie gesagt kein Gewinn für
die liberale russische Opposition
sondern die Ereignisse sind haben die
russische liberale Opposition ja
eigentlich sprachlos da stehen lassen
unvorbereitet interessanterweise also
man hat ja relativ wenig
Eingreifen von den Liberalen gespielt
sondern das ist ein Machtkampf zwischen
rechts und rechts es hatte sich
zu Wort gemeldet ne aber ansonsten
haben sich natürlich zu Wort gemeldet
aber nicht mit einem Konzept ja ja sie
haben sie Situation beschrieben und ja
teilweise unterschiedlich bewertet
interessanterweise
sehr interessant aber es ist steckt ja
kein Konzepte dahinter also die liberale
Opposition hat ja kein Konzept zu
präsentieren und hat auch keinen
Rückhand in der Bevölkerung dafür mehr
das einzige was ich mitbekommen habe das
eben in kleineren und größeren
russischen Städten schon von liberalen
und linken AktivistInnen Vorbereitungen
getroffen worden sind also zum Beispiel
Vorbereitung humanitärer Hilfe falls
diese benötigt wird dann natürlich
Einkaufen von von Vorräten
Essensvorräten Medizin und dann der
Versuch Informationen unter die Leute zu
bringen weil man muss das ganz klar
sagen die meisten Fallen die ältere
Generation wusste immer noch nicht wer
hat die Golden oder PNC Wagner ist also
obwohl wir diese Bilder aus Rostock
gesehen haben das waren 200 Leute auf
den Straßen der Rest ist ja zu Hause
geblieben also man darf das jetzt auch
nicht so zeichnen als wäre jetzt ganz
Russland den Aufruhr der Großteil der
Bevölkerung schläft nach wie vor es gibt
keine Hoffnung dass die Bevölkerung
jetzt aufwacht und sich auch
glasklarschen Seite schlägt aber genauso
wenig gibt es die Hoffnung dass die
Leute jetzt anfangen das Regime
abzuschütteln aber also die ein Großteil
der Bevölkerung kennt doch aber ich habe
sie jetzt gerade so verstanden dass sie
sagen die älteren Menschen in Russland
wissen gar nicht wer er ist genau also
der Aktivist mit dem ich gestern
angesprochen habe er meinte eben zu mir
dass man den Leuten schon erklären muss
wer eigentlich pregorian ist wer
eigentlich die Gruppe Wagner ist und das
nur die politisch interessierten Leute
und das sind in Russland nicht besonders
viele dass die politisch interessierten
Leute wissen wer ist ansonsten verfolgen
die Leute das nicht so die Leute trinken
Kaffee die Leute genießen den Sommer und
die Leute leben in massiver Armut und
sind mit ihrem eigenen Zeug beschäftigt
und das muss man ganz klar sagen gut
gucken wir aber noch mal auf die
russischen Truppen das war ja eigentlich
also oder wollen Sie darauf reagiert
genau
in meinen Augen ist was wird aus der
Gruppe Wagner ist die ohne Periode noch
so Kampf ist der wahrscheinlich
kampffähigste Teil der russischen Armee
gewesen in letzter Zeit funktioniert das
noch ohne den Mann und wenn es nur mit
dem Mann funktioniert dann ist er wieder
da dann sind wir genau bei dem Szenario
von dem ich vorhin gesprochen habe dann
kommt da einfach wieder zurück dann war
Putins ganze Handlung völlig wertlos
dann ist der Machtposition der Feuerwehr
das ist das ein und die zweite Frage die
ich mir stelle ist was bedeutet das für
den normalen russischen Soldaten den ich
Wagner
kämpft sondern in der Armee wenn die
russischen Soldaten kriegen ja auch ein
bisschen was mit wenn du dieses
Affentheater und diesen Zirkus verfolgen
dann werden die sich schon die Frage
stellen warum sie sterben sollen an
einer Front während im Machtzentrum
alles drunter drüber geht die russische
Armee ist eh frustriert heruntergekommen
schlecht versorgt und die werden sich
diese Frage jetzt sehr sehr deutlich
stellen und das sagt dann viel auch
vielleicht darüber aus ob die Chancen
der Ukraine wachsen und das
interessanteste fand ich eine Bemerkung
eines stellvertretenden Geheimdienstes
der gesagt hat das Ganze ist einfach
zwei drei Wochen zu früh gekommen oder
hättest zwei drei Wochen länger dauern
müssen dann hätte man Vorteil davon
gehabt aber warum war das denn nicht so
lange gedauert das gestern haben viele
noch auch ihre Korrespondenten von
Bürgerkrieg gesprochen ja von dem
größten Ereignis der letzten 50 Jahre in
Russland und das war alles innerhalb von
wenigen Stunden abgeblasen kommt Ihnen
das nicht verdächtig vor und es kann
genauso gut sein wenn ich das noch sagen
darf das ist und noch mal wie ich eben
gesagt habe zu einem
mobilisierungseffekt kommt und man jetzt
sagt so wir stehen geschlossen da wir
haben gezeigt dass wir einig sind das
wird ja jetzt vermittelt und
werden auch entsprechend in der Ukraine
agieren es läuft ja gar nicht so
schlecht für die Russen im Moment und
der Zar ist der Zar geblieben das muss
man einfach sagen
Putins Position sehe ich bisher nicht
geschwächt das kann so sein es kann auch
sein dass sie Recht haben nur ich bitte
zu bedenken dass es auch ganz anders
sein könnte das wir sind wieder beim
inszenierten also wir haben hier einfach
ein dezent wie Sie sehen Putins
Positionen durchaus gestärkt durch alles
was passiert ist äh die drei Kollegen
hier eher nicht ich möchte noch mal
eingehen darf der normale russische
Soldat ja der ja entweder ein einber ist
oder ein Berufssoldat finde ich auch
eine sehr interessante Frage wird der in
Zukunft dann neben sollten dann der
wagnertruppe kämpfen Sachen die ja
teilweise ein sehr zweifelhaften Ruf
genießen also was macht das wirklich so
mit der mit der Moral der russischen
Truppen in der Ukraine die Frage ist ja
lässt sich diese wagnergruppe wie sie es
der Verteidigungsminister sich
vorstellen die Armee integrieren das
sind Leute mit einer
gefängnisvergangenheit die haben hier
einen eigenen in Anführungszeichen ihr
eigenes standesetos die handeln anders
und da spielt Gregorian eine große Rolle
weil er selber ein Lager in Sasse war
der weiß wie man mit diesen Leuten redet
ich glaube normale russische Offizier
heißt das wahrscheinlich nicht so und da
die alle aus sozusagen aus einem aus von
dieselben Wurzeln haben deswegen sind
die so leistungsfähig deswegen Opfern
diese Leute sich weil sie ihre
strafreiheit dafür bekommen ob das ein
russischer Offizier von denen abverlang
da wäre ich skeptisch wir müssen uns
auch angucken in welchem Zustand die
russische Armee ist das ist sie ja nicht
erst seit Beginn des Ukraine Krieges ich
meine das ist eine Armee die wurde in
den vergangenen Jahren massiv
heruntergewirtschaftet Korruption ist
ein riesen Thema
Folter Misshandlung bis zu Mord an
Soldaten sind Teile der russischen
Disziplinierung von Soldaten also die
Moral und Professionalität dieser Armee
das haben wir im Ukraine Krieg erlebt
sind natürlich maßgebliche Ursache für
das große Scheitern das sind keine
Soldaten die über Moral verfügen und ich
meine wenn man in der Ukraine war und
erlebt hat was russische Soldaten und
nicht nur säugler dort hinterlassen
haben man muss sich mal vorstellen das
sind reguläre Truppen die fallen in Orte
ein plündern Supermärkte fallen in
Wohnungen ein vergewaltigen Frauen
betrinken sich das ist die russische
Armee das solche Armee ist eine solche
Armee keinen erfolgreichen Krieg führen
kann das liegt auf der Hand wir erleben
das und ich glaube dazu braucht es gar
nicht viel mehr Zweifel und gar nicht
viel mehr scheitern ich sehe nicht dass
die russische Armee sich auf Dauer in
diesem Krieg in der Ukraine durchsetzen
kann das werden wir heute auf jeden Fall
nicht abschließend beraten können wir
sind leider schon am Ende der Sendung
angekommen ich weiß sie wollten gerade
noch was sagen das war der Presseclub
von heute zum Thema Aufstand in Russland
wie geht es jetzt dort weiter danke für
Ihr Interesse wenn sie im ersten bleiben
gibt es jetzt im Anschluss dass
europa-magazin sie können aber auch
Presseclub nachgefragt verfolgen auf
Phoenix WDR 5 und in den sozialen Medien
danke für Ihr Interesse einen schönen
Sonntag noch
[Musik]
und da sind wir schon mit Presseclub
nachgefragt auf Phoenix WDR 5 und den
sozialen medienaufstand in Russland
erodiert Putins macht ist unsere Frage
heute und wir haben jetzt eine gute
Viertelstunde um auch noch die Stimmen
von Menschen zu hören die diese Sendung
verfolgt haben und jetzt hier noch
direkt Fragen stellen können ich fange
mal an mit Sascha lange aus
Wolfratshausen guten Tag und ihre Frage
an die Runde bitte ja guten Tag in die
Runde
meine Frage ist was wir denn von dem
Putin Regime aus dieser
aus diesem Vorgehen lernen können die
das Pudding hat ja sehr schnell nachdem
es wirklich unter Druck gekommen ist
durch den Truppe hat verhandelt und die
Frage ist würde das nicht für den Westen
heißen dass man jetzt die keine sehr
viel stärker noch stärker unterstützen
müsste um das Putin Regime zu verhandeln
zeigen aus meiner Sicht sieht man aus
den Vorfällen gestern das Putin sehr
schnell auf Verhandlungen eingeht wenn
seine Machtbasis tatsächlich bedroht ist
und nicht dass man aufs konziliantentum
mit ihm verhandeln kann Putin das Putin
Regime verhandelt ausschließlich wenn es
unter Druck ist und das wäre die
Folge dass der Westen mehr Unterstützung
für die Ukraine zukommen lässt damit
dieser Konflikt schneller beendet wird
ja ich könnte mir vorstellen hier gibt
es zwei Meinungen am Tisch dazu deshalb
erste Frau Tiramisu war bitte
ich bin die Antwort klar ja auch ein
bisschen schon in der Frage dass die
Waffenlieferungen ansteigen müssen für
die Ukraine wir haben gestern gesehen
dass der russische Staat der eh nur noch
auf dem Rechte stärkeren basiert sich
faktisch abgeschafft hat also das
Strafverfahren was gegen die Goschen
eröffnet wurde wurde eingestellt
alle sollten die mitgewirkt haben an dem
Aufstand werden nicht belangt also
faktisch haben wir eigentlich gesehen
dass das Putin Regime überhaupt nicht
mehr fähig ist die Eliten geschlossen
hinter sich zu vereinen und die Folge
daraus wäre ja mit Putin kann verhandelt
werden aber eben nur durch sehr viel
Druck deshalb würde ich Ihnen da absolut
zustimmen sie dürfen aber auch reagieren
muss man die Ukraine stärker
unterstützen damit Druck auf Putin
ausgeführt wird um auch dort zu
verhandeln
im Moment ist es glaube ich noch zu früh
zu verhandeln davor hat auch
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg gewarnt
hat von einem Scheinfrieden indirekt
gesprochen man muss die Ukraine
natürlich stärker unterstützen aber das
hätte man auch schon vor Monaten machen
müssen weil nur Erfolge auf dem
Schlachtfeld oder auf dem Kriegsfeld
werden die Ukraine in eine starke
Verhandlungsposition bringen am
Verhandlungstisch
die Frage ist warum macht man nicht mehr
warum macht man nur so dosierte
Lieferungen warum werden nicht mehr
Patrick Raketen geschickt warum werden
nicht mehr ihres geschickt warum werden
keine Kampfjets geschickt noch kein Land
hat bisher Kampfjet versprochen die die
Ukraine so dringend braucht sie hat eine
sehr schlechte Luftverteidigung und
trotzdem passiert es nicht
die Frage die Antwort darauf ist dass
man wahrscheinlich
nur dosierte Lieferung macht um den
Konflikt nicht weiter eskalieren zu
lassen und es zu einem Punkt kommt wo
möglicherweise dann wo Putin so stark
unter Druck ist dass er erweckt
taktische Atomwaffen einzusetzen
aber ihr Ansatz ist glaube ich richtig
man müsste maximalen Druck auf Putin
ausüben aber das geht im Moment nur
durch Erfolge auf dem Kriegsschauplatz
und die sind eben nicht da das muss man
leider sagen auch wenn 130
Quadratkilometer in den letzten zwei
Wochen
zurückerobert worden sind das ist aber
in Anbetracht der Verluste an Soldaten
und an Kriegsgerät mehrere Leopards
mehrere Bradley Kampfpanzer 18 Stück
sind zerstört worden ist das nicht
realistisch
danke wir wollen ja auch möglichst viele
Menschen hier in die Sendung reinholen
wir sind jetzt am Chiemsee im Süden der
Republik Bernau und Herr Josef hubig
möchte etwas von dieser Runde Wissen
hallo ja
Frage ohne große Vorräte
reden sie weiter ja ja wir hören Sie wir
spielen sie weiter kann sich aus der
Aktion des wagt dafür was brigosh ihn
eine neue Kriegsstrategie der Russen im
Norden der Ukraine von Belarus aus
entwickeln
er ist ja jetzt er soll ja jetzt noch
Belarus gehen pregorian und könnte er
möglicherweise von dort aus dann anders
die Ukraine angreifen ja ich glaube wir
wissen es alle nicht aber was würde
möglicherweise dafür sprechen Fragen
doch also ich sehe im Moment das ist
wirklich so spekulativ dass ich dann
nicht vermarkten eine Antwort da darauf
zu geben also
es gibt natürlich Gründe die dafür
sprechen dass die Strategie von
russischer Seite durchaus noch mal eine
Korrektur erfahren kann aber wie die
aussehen kann also dass das von
belarussischer Seite aus jetzt passieren
wird ich sehe dafür im Moment keinen
Anzeichen
danke ich bleibe erstaunlicherweise in
Bernau am Chiemsee bei Markus Hoffmann
der ist vielleicht ein Nachbar des
vorherigen Anrufers oder sie gucken
zusammen wie auch immer oder ist es
reiner Zufall Herr Hoffmann welche Frage
haben sie an die Runde ja also
hallo in die Runde ich habe folgende
Frage irgendwie wir haben euch das
Vorlieben vom Herrn sehr höchst
kriminell deswegen Bewaffnung falsch
verurteilt worden
ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung die auch
in Afrika
brutalsten Menschenrechte verletzt und
die Frage ist hat diese die
Stabilisierung Russlands die er vom
Besten betrieben wird auch ökonomisch
also geht's wirklich jetzt nur darum dem
Putin abzusetzen die Frage ist was kommt
danach müssen wir dann mit solchen
brigochiens wir kennen das ja aus Afrika
mit den Warlord
ja müssen wir dann mit den Warlords
verhandeln und ich möchte nebenbei noch
bemerken dass dieser Warlord der dann in
Moskau residieren würde auf Atomwaffen
den Zugriff hat danke ja Herr Hoffmann
das waren jetzt auch wieder viele
Etappen für die Zukunft die wir jetzt so
nicht beurteilen können aber die Frage
ist ja tatsächlich was ist wenn Putin
jetzt dauerhaft geschwächt wäre und wir
gegebenenfalls mit anderen Leuten
verhandeln müssen ja aber venarius ich
würde sich immer so auf einzelne Figuren
abstellen
der russische Staatsapparat ist ein
System mit verschiedenen Kraftfeldern
und wenn verhandelt wird dann verhandelt
da nicht ein Mann da verhandeln da nicht
zwei Männer oder zwei Frauen sondern da
stehen die Apparate gegeneinander ich
glaube das ist das geringste Problem und
das bregorian die Macht im Kreml
übernimmt ich glaube davon sind wir noch
relativ weit entfernt
trotzdem könnte es ja wenn Putin
geschwächt wird tatsächlich dazu kommen
dass wir mit anderen Menschen also wir
im Westen mit anderen Menschen
verhandeln müssen und ob das dann besser
wird als Putin oder nicht weiß man jetzt
natürlich
ich glaube schon dass wenn Putins macht
erodiert es dazu kommen könnte das
Russland darüber kurz oder lang zerfällt
vielleicht in kleine diskutieren
vielleicht gibt es ein antikoloniales
Erwachen von denen russländischen
Minderheiten die sich in die Demokratie
hinaus kämpfen wollen das ist alles
natürlich auch eine Utopie meinerseits
aber dieses Szenarien sind nicht
unvorstellbar deshalb es könnte sein
dass ich Russland verkleinert wie es
weiterhin mit dispoten zu tun haben aber
naja das ist eben dann unterschiedliche
vielleicht neue
Kalender starten gibt gut das sind jetzt
wie sie schon gesagt haben ihre
persönlichen Zukunftswünsche soweit sind
wir tatsächlich noch nicht ich gehe vom
institutive tatsächlich auch also ein
mögliches Szenario bestimmen aber soweit
soweit sind wir noch nicht jetzt gehe
ich mal in den Norden der Republik zu
Klaus Borchert moin moin nach Hamburg ja
moin moin
Schleswig-Holstein aber an der Grenze zu
Hamburg so viel zu dem Thema sehr sehr
einfaches Herr Putin ist wirklich
angeschlagen gewesen also die Rede die
jetzt von Anfang gehalten hat da war
Schaum vom Mund haben können also davon
parisert und so sprach ich sehe
henrikorin gregorien als toten Mann
die effektivste Art und Weise für Putin
darzustellen dass er das hat er in der
Hand hat ist
zeitnah zu beweisen der Mann ist tot der
ist als Sieger gesprungen und endet als
bettpflege bzw als Profil von den Vater
von den Touren der Stadt die im
Mittelalter aufgespießt der Kopf auf
eine Lanze und dem Volk zu zeigen ich
habe die macht hier also ich glaube
nicht dass der gregorien da also sehr
überlegt gehandelt hat das ist wenn man
glaube ich gar nicht in der Lage gut
also sie Fragen vor allem wird
die nächsten Tage überleben wie geht's
mit dem
weitergeschoben
ja genau wie geht's weiter also nicht
dass wir es wüssten aber was könnte
passieren
das Schlimmste für Putin ist ein
Verräter er wird versuchen diesen Mann
zu beseitigen oder der Mann ist ja auch
vorgewarnt der wird schon wissen wie er
sich schützen kann
das weiß keiner und Putin hat viele
seiner Gegner ermordet aber gregorien
hat sehr viel Geld und er hat sehr viel
Kämpfer also ich sehe ihn morgen noch
nicht tot oder den Kopf auf der Lande
was wir erleben ist ja das prägurien
hat ja in dieser Situation etwas
eskaliert was schon viel viel länger
zurückliegt er hat ja die Macht mehrfach
schon in Frage gestellt er hat ja zum
Beispiel die Oligarchen auf Wüste
beschimpft und beschuldigt auf dem
Rücken des russischen Volkes sich zu
bereichern und solche Dinge ähm ich sehe
nicht das Putin sich gegen Prägung
in einer Form durchsetzen wird wie der
Herr das jetzt gerade etwas drastisch
beschrieben hat sondern hätte er das
doch längst tun können ich glaube wir
dürfen nicht unterschätzen wie sehr
Putin auf pregorien angewiesen ist und
war sonst hätte er ihn auch nicht so
lange gewähren lassen in dem Tonfall und
in der Art wie er aufgetreten ist gegen
im Prinzip das Militär des Landes ja und
ich finde die spannende Frage ist ja was
hat sich Prägung herausgehandelt und das
wissen wir nicht das müssen wir noch ein
bisschen gedulden uns vielleicht werden
wir es auch nie erfahren aber
solange gehen wir erstmal weiter nach
Hessen zu einem Städtchen oder einem
Dorf das heißt Ortenberg Herr Marc
Hebbel bitte guten Tag und ihre Frage
ja hallo in die Runde guten Morgen
dass die Frau Eigendorf ein super Job
macht ich sehe sie immer weil ich
öffentlich rechtlich gucke und meine
Frage ist jetzt die russische
Öffentlichkeit bekommt ja gar nichts mit
was in Russland geschieht die gucken nur
alle das russische Fernsehen und
bekommen ja gar nicht mit was ich
gestern den ganzen Tag leider Gottes nur
auf den privatrundfunk RTL und welt.de
sehen konnte bis ich endlich mal Phoenix
eingeschaltet hat Frage an die Frau
Eigendorf wie bekommen die russischen
Bürger überhaupt außer Telegramm
irgendwas mit von der ganzen Situation
in Russland
Eugendorf ja also das Problem für den
Zugang zu Informationen ist klar dieser
Staat hat die Information unter seiner
Kontrolle es gibt natürlich die
Möglichkeit über VPN Leitungen sich
Zugang zu YouTube zu verschaffen sich im
Netz zu informieren aber ich würde mal
von einer anderen Seite kommen besteht
überhaupt das Interesse bei der Mehrheit
der russischen Bevölkerung an diesen
Ereignissen ich sehe das nicht wir im
Westen hier haben diese Ereignisse
wirklich atemlos verfolgt und praktisch
ja am Bildschirm geklebt wir alle weil
das uns und ja im Prinzip die
Entwicklung der der globalen Sicherheit
betrifft ich sehe das bei den Russen
nicht die Russen leben ihr Leben wir
beobachten doch im den letzten 16
Monaten eine große Gleichgültigkeit was
die Ereignisse in der Ukraine angeht das
ist nicht der Krieg des russischen
Volkes gegen die Ukraine sondern das ist
ein Krieg den man einfach hinnimmt ich
vermisse sehr Empathie für doch Menschen
die man als Bruder Volk mal gesehen hat
ich glaube dass die Mehrheit der
russischen Bevölkerung wie die Kollegin
das auch gerade schon vorhin angedeutet
hat mit ganz anderen Problemen
beschäftigt ist mit dem täglichen
versorgen mit den eigenen Notlagen und
die Mehrheit der russischen Bevölkerung
hat sich in den letzten 23 Jahren in
diesem Regime immer immer weiter ins
Private zurückgezogen und die die
wirklich damals für demokratische
Verhältnisse eingetreten sind die
liberale Opposition ist entweder tot im
Westen oder im Gefängnis
ja das ist tatsächlich das Bittere Bild
der russischen Gesellschaft aktuell was
sie jetzt gerade gezeichnet haben wir
haben noch Zeit für einen Anrufer für
Marek nillac aus Würzburg guten Tag
hallo
ich wollte nur etwas sagen nach meiner
Recherche aus Polen und aus Russland
gefällt der Tag dieser ganze Geschichte
mit Abkehr davon können
über Natur
Freund von Putin und Volker Rosin und er
hat gefetet nicht lukaschen und andere
und das war wichtige Sache weil er hat
gesagt keine weil diese Vorbereitung zum
Fußballplatz in lange Zeit vorbereitet
von Kreise von Milizen und von
verschiedenen Leute und guten Tag kein
Zeichen bekommen
wer bekommt die Moskau Unterstützung und
Juni hat ihm gesagt dann praktische fast
keine Chance darum
fassen was sie was sie gerade formuliert
haben also es ist letztendlich eine
Person die das eingefädelt hat die haben
wissende Kolleginnen mit dem Kopf
genickt die diesen möglichen Deal jetzt
eingefädelt haben von dem wir noch nicht
die genauen Ausmaße kennen was können
Sie dem Hörer Antworten aus den
russischen Oppositionellen Medien konnte
ich genau das gleiche entnehmen also
seit gestern Abend ist der Name Alex
Julian aufgetaucht Julien ähm also die
offizielle Seite hat dementiert dass er
sich beteiligt hat an den ähm Absprachen
an den Verhandlungen aber es ist
eigentlich ziemlich sicher dass er dabei
gewesen sein sollen eine große Rolle
gespielt hat es gibt jetzt die
Überlegungen dass er als neuer mächtiger
Mann in Russland jetzt an die Oberfläche
kommen könnte aber das ist natürlich
auch alles Spekulation alles noch
Spekulation damit werden wir heute
dieses nachgefragt das Presseclub
beenden wir sind tatsächlich am Ende der
Sendung angekommen vielen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung zu dem was seit gestern
passiert ist wir bleiben natürlich dran
in den nächsten Stunden Tagen und Wochen
wie sich die Situation in Russland
weiterentwickelt danke für Ihr Interesse
und einen schönen Sonntag
[Musik]